foreign
[Music]
Jack's finally done something that I
gotta say
even for Jack scalfani
this is low
this is some of the sickest
most evil
most inhumane thing I've ever seen done
to food
oh get ready guys
get your stomach's ready
it's gonna be bad
[Music]
hey guys jack scalfani here cooking with
Jack show and today we're going to be
showing you
um freeze-dried tacos that's right we're
gonna
spread everything out I'll show you how
it's all going to be done basically if
you don't know what a freeze dryer is it
literally freezes then it pulls all the
moisture out and dries it then you put
it in a mylar bag and seal it and it can
stay the food can stay safe for 20 up to
25 years no nutrition lost you can argue
with the experts if you want but this is
what I found out from all the people who
have already done this so anyway I'm
excited gonna go freeze dry my first
real meal I'm done with the bread run so
today we're doing the freeze-dried tacos
coming in close I'll show you what we're
doing they say once you get it on these
these trays that go in your freeze dryer
once you get it on these then you get it
all see now
foreign
autist is calling it space tacos
space tacos exactly
Virgie just said I looked it up the
freeze dryer is three thousand dollars
so
three thousand dollars
to freeze dry Taco why would you freeze
dried tacos
or taco ingredients
if you're gonna freeze dry stuff right
wouldn't you freeze dry like a massive
amount of ingredients
yeah I did velocity um
why would you freeze dry enough to make
a couple of tacos
freeze drying is like a useful thing
yeah sure but
tacos aren't hard to make so why
wouldn't you just
as Devil's Sunbirds saying tacos should
be eaten immediately
uh Lucian says I thought the only [ __ ]
worth freeze drying was fruit or
something I mean yeah fruits and
I don't know bowls of fruit and [ __ ]
John IV has a good point so you can have
tacos in 20 years silly ah [ __ ] spread
out then you freeze it ahead of time
before you put in the dryer it cuts down
a lot of the energy costs and the time
to freeze in the first place so that's
what I'm gonna do I'm going to pop these
in my freezer
but so here's what we're gonna do also
we're gonna cook the meat okay they say
you can do it raw if you want but the
reason you do it cooked is so when
you're ready to hydrate it again bring
it back to life and use it you already
have it flavored seasoned cooked and
you're ready to eat within 10 minutes
you'll be having tacos within 10 minutes
so let me show you what I got all right
this all is going to be spread out on
these trays and then popped in the
freezer to freeze then I'll put it in
the dry I'm going to take you all the
way through okay so this is the me I'm
gonna cook this up by the way good point
uh Virgie the amount of electricity it
could take to make these tacos could buy
you a taco box at Taco Bell
being
yeah but Jack's trying to think outside
the bun
stuff right now uh Brown it up put taco
seasoning in it
um just basically cook it up like I'm
gonna make tacos tonight but I'm not
these can be just spread normally I
don't have to do anything to them and
the cheese same way so let me get
everything prepared on trays I'll show
you the trays why we I wouldn't I
wouldn't eat 20 year old freeze-dried
cheese
thank you
this meal is a haker I told you that
this was going to be the worst thing
Jack's ever done
I mean again I
I'm not even against you saying all
right you know what we're gonna fire up
this freeze-drying thing I'm going to
show you how to freeze dry stuff but
tacos white tacos
that's not a freeze dry friendly like
this was a great opportunity for you to
go like I'm gonna show you how to make
you know how to freeze dry a bunch of
blueberries and [ __ ] so that you're all
set for the [ __ ] you know what I mean
you're all set for the Apocalypse
this is gonna come out so bad before
they go into the freezer
all right we got it all prepped so we
got the taco meat cooked and seasoned
got our Mexi cheese down here got our
salsa in this tray and have spread out
the guacamole now when I was learning
about freeze drying I'm squawk mole
still an idiot I'm learning with you
guys this could fail I may be freeze
drying something you can't freeze-dried
he doesn't even know
you can freeze dry guacamole though
it's gross though I don't know why you
would do that isn't guacamole like
that's avocado right our avocado it
isn't like aren't avocados and guacamole
aren't they only good
for like 10 minutes
am I wrong but isn't that one of those I
don't like guacamole and I don't like
avocados so I don't eat it
um
but am I is that am I right about that
it's not one of the ones that like you
buy an avocado and it goes bad in like
12 hours you know what I mean like or
you [ __ ] make guac and it's just
terrible it like guacamole goes bad
halfway through a party
well I need a beer I'll try it out
anyway I'm going for it I don't care
these are all going in the freezer and
we're gonna freeze this for 24 to 48
hours
then we're gonna pop it in the freeze
dryer and freeze dry these tacos this
taco stuff all right then once we're
done we'll rehydrate it we'll get it
back to normal again we'll wait a couple
days get it back to normal and try it
out but in the meantime this tray here
may have issues because it has a kind of
an oily base which complicates the
process
wouldn't you want to freeze dry stuff
that actually is expensive
and things that would potentially
not be in existence in the future right
tacos and the ingredients that go into
tacos are generally cheap
and plentiful
there's a reason why
it was such a popular food item in
Central America and [ __ ] because if you
got a decent [ __ ] if you have a
decent geography and you have like you
know some farmable land
any basic [ __ ] Society can get beef
and cheese and some vegetables you know
what I mean put together so it's like
tacos are
why would you just take cheap shredded
cheese cheap meat and then freeze dry
it's like wouldn't you want to freeze
dry some [ __ ]
that's gonna be super expensive and rare
in the future
uh Virgie he ran a freeze dryer for 48
hours so that he could make tacos faster
I [ __ ] hate this man oh my God you're
right because he wants to be able to
just make it on the go fat uh
process of freeze drying what I was told
I don't know I'm learning as we go but
anyway and then these three should be
okay so I I did hear guacamole is
possible and sauce is definitely
possible so let's get these in the
freezer and then we'll pick this video
up in about a day or so
[Music]
frozen solid yep so let's give it a day
guys you know I'm gonna update you on
these heads Virgie just pointed out give
me a full 24 hours and then I'll update
you on these tacos
who's making these tacos Mr yes
Jack's showing us how to make Mr yes
tacos
guys we're having tacos in 48 hours
all right
do you know what we're having tonight
it's got the salsa Frozen Rich this is
[ __ ] ah I [ __ ] up he says if Rich says
his [ __ ] arm is freeze-dried I [ __ ]
it up I'm sorry guys you already have it
flavored seasoned cooked I don't know
I'm learning as we go video up in about
a day or so once these are frozen solid
he's got the salsa frozen solid he's
from Salt Lake guacamole from the solid
meat frozen solid
got that thing saying to load the trays
in
so we're about ready to get this thing
going okay you can see up close all the
trays are loaded let's close the door
all right the door is all closed you can
see the food is in there
they've been frozen and
the chamber is getting Frozen right now
with the temperatures dropping we're at
31 degrees right now
for a few minutes it's freezing then
it's gonna start sucking the moisture
out of that are you tired of having to
are you tired of your tacos being too
easy to eat and make
foreign
s where it like shows them in black and
white like
that's what we need we need we need an
infomercial where they're like are you
tired of your tacos being too easy to
make and it's just somebody being like
with all these toppings in their hand
like freaking out
nuisance is damn that's a nice air for a
freezer Air Dryer too I hate this [ __ ]
yeah he sucks and he gets all these
gadgets for free food
so I gotta go get my bags for storing
and be ready to
store this food good morning everybody
it's been going all night
I think we're what 17 hours
and we got the cheese guacamole salsa
and meat and I believe they're all going
to be fairly dried out now so now we're
gonna break them up and bring them over
here we've got our specially labeled
this is
so much work
for shitty what are going to be
shitty tacos
now
what you could have done
would you just Brown up the meat and you
[ __ ] mix in the [ __ ] salt
seasoning you cut up a tomato you cut up
a little [ __ ] lettuce you cut up a
little onion if that's your thing
you get some cheese
some shells if you want to make
tortillas you sell whatever but it
should be
tacos should be something you make
and you're eating them 11 minutes later
you just ruined food and you've wasted
time and electricity
bags with the date and the name
and we've got the sealer and we've got
the oxygen absorbers one of those I
didn't know what those were but now I
know what they are therefore removing
oxygen in a package or a container
you can even use glass jars if you want
you can drop one of those in there we're
about ready to rehydrate our food let's
move these bowls for a second
as you can see the guacamole is in here
it's air packed tight there's an oxygen
absorber inside as you can see I got the
cooked taco meat in here I've got the
Woody massive waste of time and
resources
oh
oxygen absorbers Jack you're a [ __ ]
oxygen absorber Tammy sees you as a
[ __ ] massive oxygen absorber
salsa in here I've got shredded cheese
in this one okay so the other beautiful
thing we got them all in the bowls the
other beautiful thing is it will only
take as much water as it needs but if it
needs more you'll see there's no more
water so you want to add a little bit
more water until it's done drinking does
that make sense this is how you
rehydrate so we're gonna put a little
bit in here
we can give that a little bit of time
put a little bit in there this is
disgusting put a little bit in here
okay a little bit in here
and you want it to become back to its
consistency
so you can take like your your guac
Stir It Around
until it turns back it's all going to be
thin soupy [ __ ]
and a guacamole beautiful
okay
your salsa until it comes back into
salsa
I may put too much in this you can add
more
there you go your cheese
it takes a few minutes to rehydrate
we're going to drain all this stuff once
it's soaked for a little bit let it get
all the water at once let it drink
there we go let it rehydrate this meat
feels like the meat the day I made it
feels good I'm smelling the meat right
now with the seasoning because the
meat's cooked already so the taco smell
is in the air at the moment
a quick little taco here a little meat
over here
here we go got a little bit of cheese oh
God it's just good whoops my meat's
going all over the place get over here
there we go I want a little more cheese
there we go got some cheese
got some guacamole
lots of guac that's great there we go
take a little bit of salsa
all rehydrated we're gonna try this out
and see how the flavors lasted
okay guys
time to try this Taco out really quick
here we go if there was ever a moment
[Music]
no nothing white looped I shouldn't have
done that oh
tastes like we just put it together
well yeah it tastes like you just put it
together I mean
you food [ __ ] anyway
[Music]
nothing tastes different tastes like the
day I put it in the freeze dryer
came back to life it's there now we're
gonna be doing some more testing some
more examples we're gonna go a year out
we're gonna go a month out we're gonna
go a couple years out I'm gonna do a
test where I freeze dry a bunch of
chicken breasts and we're gonna check
like after a year after two years we're
gonna go throughout the Shelf
Harvest Right
you guys got a great device I'm excited
if you guys are interested link down
below there's your freeze-dried tacos
perfect they came out great
good job buddy get em boys
this is the laps we know that you are in
put your one hand up step out now with
your hands in the air Jack
I don't want to be around anymore Jack
I find you guilty
I find you guilty of capital
crimes at this point
crimes against food
crimes against
the General Health and Welfare of the
public
I consider you a danger
and I am sentencing you
to A Thousand Years of hard labor with
one arm
that's my ruling
may God
have mercy on your soul
for crimes against the Latino Community
is lock on Stratos if
you if you if you told the Mexicans you
were locking jack up for this they'd be
like can you start with the the blacks
in my neighborhood because they honestly
uh more danger to me my children
I have to fix a lock on my shed like
four times
four times
it's too many times all right let's uh